java a boilerplate driven language
designed for writing verbose
object-oriented instant legacy code it
came into being thanks to a relentless
hype campaign by sun microsystems in the
middle of the dot-com bubble it's kind
of like the macaulay culkin of
programming languages it was originally
invented to create a better tv remote
than it officially launched for public
use in 1996 and nobody's bothered to
update the website ever since regardless
java has been running on 3 billion
devices for the last 25 years most of
which are blu-ray players its motto is
right once run everywhere which
developers know actually means write
once debug everywhere remember the log4j
fiasco you can blame java for that one
still java has a great mascot a little
one-eyed monster named duke and people
love to hate it so much that it's
inspired an entire class of programming
languages designed to make java better
like groovy closure scala and kotlin
just to name a few unfortunately though
there is no cure java also inspired
javascript a language that has taken
developers 25 years to make halfway
decent and one time java even tried to
steal javascript's job with applets on
the web luckily applet sucks so bad they
made html css and javascript look like a
good abstraction for building uis now
when your company adopts java you'll
also want to adopt oracle database so
you can spend the next 20 years talking
about migrating to postgres while paying
an ungodly amount of money that will be
directly reinvested into these awesome
sailing yachts to get started set aside
a few days to install the jdk jre and
jvm on your machine it's also
recommended that you have a vertical
monitor to read the error logs that are
coming now before writing any code say
this with me public static void main
string args public static void main
string args now to say hello world
create a class java forces you into
object oriented programming which means
you'll want to read design patterns
cover to cover before you go any further
now it's time for your public static
void main string args and then finally
system.out.printline with hello world as
you can see we get a lot more
boilerplate than something like python
which is a feature and definitely not a
fundamental design flaw or anything
you'll want to start by writing one
giant bloated class then when your boss
complains break it into a hierarchy of
deeply nested subclasses that will make
it impossible to refactor the next step
is to ragequit from your job life is way
too short to be coding in java man and
with that i think i've lost enough
subscribers for one video there are only
two kinds of languages the ones people
complain about and the ones nobody uses
whether you love it or hate it jabba can
get stuff done and for that it deserves
our respect thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one